what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard Series today I'm going to be
doing part two of why women should info
so if you guys saw my appearance on
Pierce Morgan you'll see that I argue
that women should not have the right to
vote and I also have a whiteboard video
where I explain uh why I don't think
women should have the right to vote now
part of this is because women do not
offer the same value to societies the
whole point of feminism is to say men
and women are equal so the men offer
equal value to society as women now and
I think that this premise is just false
it cannot be true now you might think
Pearl that's sexist don't you hate women
why would you want to take the right to
vote away from yourself well
I start to look at the numbers so first
of all women didn't even want the right
to vote only five percent of women even
wanted the right to vote let's let's
take the anti-esophage out of it and
let's just look at the value added to
society now what is value added value is
output in a way so the definition of
value is the regard that something is
held to deserve the important Worth or
usefulness of something so how useful
are women to society is the question now
the first question is should we give
privilege based on how useful someone is
to society I would say yes I would say
yes now a lot of people say you can't
measure value but I really think you can
so couple stats so men run the
infrastructure of society they pay the
majority of the taxes so a common
complaint I got was like Pearl well then
a lot of men shouldn't vote what percent
of men even do those jobs so I look
looked it up for you guys out of the
kindness of my heart if we include
because you know we have to Define what
is the infrastructure so I included
farming I included manufacturing I
included Transportation
um I included building the buildings
Paving the roads uh the jobs that mostly
men do in a small percentage of women do
all right so 13.7 percent of men have
jobs that are associated with the
infrastructure either public or private
sector construction Power Water roads
but not including truck drivers and
other transports so I would consider
truck drivers necessary I live in a city
how would I get food without my truck
driver so if we include truck drivers
and Farmers we need food right that goes
up to 24.4 percent of men then if we add
mining workers an Associated field
workers it gets to 26.2 percent of men
now what about Factory workers how how
did this get constructed how did all the
stuff we have in this apartment get
constructed Factory so that goes up to
35.9 percent of men then we think about
protection electricity Plumbing
manufactured goods we go up to
35.9 and if we include the military
police and firemen we got 44 of men that
work in running the infrastructure of
society so one in two men is that not do
you think that's significant or is that
insignificant is this okay so now
remember women do teaching we do nursing
but if those jobs went away the
infrastructure of society would still
run we would still have food we would
still have water we would still have a
military so almost one in two men run
the infrastructure of society so there
are some beta ass YouTubers that are
like well I I stream I'm just a streamer
maybe I shouldn't maybe I shouldn't vote
by this logic well if you don't employ
anybody I might say yes and this doesn't
even include the men that run the
Fortune 500 companies and business
owners because if you include that those
are people that hire people because
women tend to have smaller businesses
men tend to have bigger businesses so so
okay 44 of men what percent of women run
the infrastructure what percent do you
think 0.5 percent it higher than you
think so for the women it is
7.69 percent of women run the
infrastructure of society and that
breaks down 2.81 comes from Factory
workers infrastructure workers is 1.78
and police staff one percent do we
really believe the female police
officers are as needed as the male ones
are they really Gonna Hold Us Down if
hits the fan infrastructure workers
the plumbers and electricians are they
really are they holding the sign are
they holding the flag for construction
on the side of the road or are they the
ones really doing it come on guys be
honest be honest so the first part of
running the infrastructure of society
men do more so men do the harder jobs in
terms of value now you know what maybe
maybe maybe the men like the women were
just starting to out earn men and make
all this money maybe we're paying more
tax taxes right wrong wrong men pay more
taxes they pay they pay sixty percent of
the taxes okay well maybe women are just
better than with money right maybe women
I mean we may not make as much but we're
just more responsible they always say
women mature faster than men but we're
just so much more responsible wrong
wrong we hold two-thirds of debt so we
make less money we do the easier jobs
and we have more debt now but you know
what maybe women should have an equal
say right because you know we we give
life right right King we we bring life
to the world so isn't that valuable to a
society we bring life we bring Purity oh
no we do not so the birth rate has
dropped below
1.64 kids per women so less than two
kids a chick and they're projecting that
50 of us are going to be single and
childless so only and we're no longer 95
of us aren't virgins on our wedding
nights though the majority of us we
don't bring Purity to the market we
bring more debt when we do the easier
jobs now knowing all this information
can we really say that men and women are
equal that we contribute you equally to
society why should we have an equal say
now I am open to suggestions guys it
could be net taxpayers because by that
logic still men would be the majority of
the voters um it could be only the men
that are only the people that are in the
military or the infrastructure can vote
which would also lead to men voting the
majority my point is why do we get the
most say when we do the least amount of
work women you cannot win an election as
a politician without catering to women
you have to get the female vote and the
majority of the Swing voters are single
women so now we have all of the
politicians catering to women who don't
offer equal value now you can say that
maybe as a woman I shouldn't advocate
for this but I think we should advocate
for a society that is fair and the way
this is set up women are doing the most
useless jobs we have the majority of the
debt we're not having children we're not
getting married and yet we want an equal
say to men but I don't know guys let me
know maybe I'm wrong maybe Pearl's just
a misogynist I just hate women and I'm
just a dummy YouTuber who doesn't know
anything according to these beta-ass
simp ass reaction channels who don't
look at any of the numbers behind me so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments um like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time